hey there this is Jason guts and you're
listening to think again a big faint
podcast since 2008 big think has been
bringing you big ideas in little doses
from some of the most creative thinkers
around on the think again podcast we
step outside of our comfort zone
surprising our guests and me your host
with unexpected clips from big Fink's
interview archives ideas that we didn't
necessarily come here prepared to
discuss this is the fourth mixtape that
I'm doing of some of the highlights of
the first year of the show which is time
to reflect back and think about where
we've been as you may have noticed if
you're following the show I have a lot
of creative writers on I'm a writer
myself and I think a lot about the craft
of writing and some of the guests have
given our listeners advice that I find
incredibly powerful and that stays with
me all the time this episode is an
attempt to round up some of those best
moments some of those most powerful
moments advice about writer's block how
to work with the creative team how to
deal with success and failure and how to
deal with the psychology of being a
writer I hope that you'll find these
moments as meaningful as I do this first
segment is from a conversation with the
acclaimed playwright and screenwriter
sir david hare he really surprised me
there was a really interesting and
unexpected turn in the middle of this
conversation that I found delightful and
the surprise clip is with feel icky
talking about the psychology of
happiness
if you look at the neuroscience the way
that we're wired has a profound effect
on how we hear and respond to feedback
we took a look at three variables that
are particularly important in terms of
your reaction to feedback the first is
your baseline it's sort of how happy or
unhappy are you in the absence of other
events in your life where's that level
that you come back to it's a scale of
one to ten some people just live their
lives at nine right there just so
unbelievably happy and cheerful about
everything this research comes from
looking at lottery winners a year later
they're about as happy or unhappy as
they were before they won the lottery
and people who go to jail a year or
later they're about as happy or unhappy
as before they went to jail now we look
at the second variable which is swing
when you get positive or negative
feedback how far off your baseline does
it knock you the same piece of feedback
can be devastating for one person and
you know kind of annoying for another
and then the third variable is how long
does it take you to come back to your
baseline how long do you sustain
positive feeling or how long does it
take you to recover from negative
feeling so taken together that's where
the big variation in sensitivity comes
from that some people are extremely
sensitive and other people are pretty
insensitive or maybe I should say even
keel but I suppose if you're insensitive
you don't really care what I call you so
it doesn't matter
so there's a lot in there the others a
lot in there well there are two
principal things yes about what she's
saying the feedback thing I work in the
collaborative arts I choose to be a
playwright rather than a novelist or a
poet and therefore for me collaboration
is absolutely essential if I'm working
on a movie set or if I'm in a rehearsal
then the whole day what I have written
is put under a degree of scrutiny and
the actors in particular will say to me
you think that in the interest of the
general story you have achieved this
scene but let me tell you from my point
of view playing it as one person in this
scene there is not enough for me here I
haven't got what I want or I can't make
sense of this change to which I can only
respond either by arguing or going back
and rewriting in order that the woman or
man who's playing this particular part
will fit into the general picture and be
able to play what they want to play in
other words they're going to put it
under a scrutiny that maybe you have
overlooked in your rush to follow the
main narrative through and so you're
making adjustments all the time and
you're accepting feedback my experience
is you can do that from a position of
confidence in other words if you're
confident about what the general
movement of the play or film is then
there is no end to the amount of input
that you're open to because you know
that it will not be destructive because
you know that the resilience of the
basic idea of what you're doing will see
you through and that the thing can't be
damaged by minor adjustments and if
you're working with great actors as I've
spent my life working with some of the
greatest actors in the world you're just
crazy not to listen to them because what
they're going to bring to it is going to
be incredibly useful to you so from that
point of view feedback is what I live on
that's that's my element an opinion
remember is the element that any
creative person has to swim in in other
words you know a play doesn't exist
until it's put before an audience and
what the audience's opinion is is what
finishes
that playoff you know when when people
want to become actors young people I say
to them you think you're going out there
and you're going to create other people
it's going to be creative I said half
your job is going to be being judged
humph your job is going to be out there
and sensing that the audience don't like
you are you up for that do you have the
kind of temperament that is going to be
able to cope with the dislike of large
numbers of people you're going to fail
in certain roles and when you fail in
certain roles in front of people it's
going to be deeply embarrassing shaming
humiliating and upsetting are you up for
that are you up for being judged and
that's what working in the collaborative
arts involves well let me ask you this
because I understand from your memoir
and just from the way you write that
you're a sensitive person you know you
were very sensitive person so when you
were just starting out as a playwright
you know if somebody had said that to
you if somebody had come and said like
do you have what it takes is your skin
thick enough would you have recoiled in
horror and crawled into a corner
completely hi i would i would not have
chosen this job if i had known the
degree of judgment that it would involve
i have sat in audiences where the
audience's rejected the play and did not
want to hear what I wanted to say to
them and in extremely page ripped my
soul out there was the night in seattle
where a film of mine was laughed off the
screen in 1987 with a test audience at a
preview audience i will never go back to
the city of seattle but listen in the
man the time available to us let's go
back to her other point which is really
interesting the happiness thing you know
that a year later the person who's in
jail is at the same level of happiness
that they were before they were injure
i'm afraid i think this is true when
you're young you have a fantasy that you
can change and that you can change your
life then you will achieve something and
then when you achieve that thing that
will make a significant difference to
your contentment index in other words
you're driven by fantasy when you're my
age there is no fantasy left you know I
am extremely happily married to
pletely wonderful woman whom I
absolutely adore my children I adore
therefore my private life could not be
any happier than sit there is no fantasy
about my I do not go to sleep dreaming
of meeting some other woman who will
transform my life I adore the person
that I am with and can imagine no better
do you see nor will I do I dream of
writing a hit play I've written hit
plays I know what a hip feels like I've
lived through it it doesn't
significantly change your life you still
have to start again and try and write
the next one so I fear that what she
says about how the sort of basic level
of happiness you have in your life
doesn't really change very much one of
my favorite conversation was with
turkeys arguably most celebrated living
novelist Orhan Pamuk who won the nobel
prize for literature here he's talking
about something I've never really heard
a writer discussed before which is the
psychology of sitting down every day to
write and how a creative writer should
manage that I find this to be incredible
advice and the surprise clip is from
psychologists vessel vanderkolk on
trauma
psychiatry has always had a complex
relationship to trauma it started off as
a discipline that looked at way back in
the 1800's people have very bizarre
reactions to trauma and so just that
define hysteria so there were some
interested in and then they put a
compassionate people no longer a large
study hysteria first world war breaks
out a huge number of traumatized guys
probably had lot to do with the rise of
Nazism and then in 1947 the last book
about war trauma gets published and
there's nothing till nineteen eighty two
or something so it takes a long time
virsa gayatri really doesn't want to see
trauma and in the currents dsm the
people call the bible of psychiatry now
we live with weird diagnosis like
oppositional defiant disorder where
people don't ask why did these kids come
become defiance bipolar disorder kids
being mentally unstable going up and
down at their emotions and psychiatry
doesn't really want to look at what's
behind there and as a consequence e
instead of looking at social conditions
as being at the origin of these
disorders these kids get drugged up last
year in the US kids got 18 point 1
billion dollars worth of psychotropic
drugs and these drugs do calm people
down but they also work on the reward
system in the brain and decrease
curiosity openness experimentation
engagement with people so they neglect
of the issue of trauma in the u.s. in
particular is a very serious public
health issue
for me the biggest trauma of life is of
course unrequited love my normal Museum
of innocence is extensively about the
illusions of flow i chronicled
upper-middle-class Turkish man's
obsession infatuation it is twice
removed cousin just like a trauma he can
never get out of it he is ridiculed and
made fun of and a trauma means you are
almost in the war your panic you don't
know what to do you want to survive and
you lack the central logic that will
control and heal you and perhaps pave
the way out of the traumatic situation
my understanding of a trauma is that you
want to get out of a situation but yet
you're so much pressure that your mind
does not give you the clue out of the
Kafkaesque way out of that problem love
is like that perhaps psychology
psychiatrist should focus about love
treated as a trauma I am against all
this glorification sugar izing put them
on a pedestal the idea of love is a
sweetie I agree is the sweetest thing
when it all comes with a bad package of
trauma longing jealousy anger
miscommunication self-obsession making
you not see the whole picture I'm a
writer in I want to be I'm a
self-conscious writer a writer who wants
to know the effects of what he or she is
doing but also there is one side to me
that makes me survive perhaps that is
letting things go just following the
music that is spontaneously coming
inside of me colors nodes words that I'm
possessed with in the end if you write
every day like me sit at a table every
day traumas and vanish perhaps because I
know that life would be
art if I was working in an office I
choose the life of the solitary artists
writing every day which avoids me from
the pressure and traumas of everyday
life but it's inevitable life is in the
end daily life I mean you are working
hard you create a structure you sit down
every day you have a discipline so
somehow those structures are sufficient
then you don't have to worry as much
about trying to control the rest in fact
I argue that a creative writer professor
should teach more about this then what
should be the plot what should be
because normative structural policies
about writing fiction is less important
than teaching the would-be writer how to
behave in life how to take easy the
regular systematic traumas writing
blocks unhappiness money happiness and
depressive slowing down being a writer
is more about minding your mental health
navigating according to your moods
what's section chapter of the book you
should write first because it's
appropriate to your moods now what to do
when you're blocked and how to skip one
chapter skip one trauma skip one problem
and continue I understand that
psychiatry address traumas I thought
they were already doing that I don't
bite the people were going to people and
paying money and because they had
traumas now I learned they go for other
reasons I would go to a psychiatrist
because I had a trauma if I were to fall
in love and never get out of long and
feel that I'm hurt or if I'm blocked by
my writing and feel that I'm scared of
something I had traumas political
representing the past in the end they
gave me nightmares but in the long run
they just pass away if you're busy with
something that makes you happy and it's
writing writing writing oh yes gave me
lots of problems but in the long run
achievement of finishing something and
being like a child playing with his toys
being Lizabeth all the time solves all
the traumas of to work I want to ask you
like when you sit down and your brain
isn't working that day does that happen
ever had weapons all the way then what
do you do Hemingway has a nice advice he
said at the end of the day if you know
what you're gonna write don't write the
last sentence keep it for the next
morning so start with that sentence once
you write a beautiful sentence that
sentence will tell you what will be the
next what will be the next what will be
the next when you're writing fiction if
you're in it age sentence you have a
magic feeling that it's unfolding on its
own you look out of your window you look
at say New York silhouette or Bosphorus
that I see from my window and my mind is
it possessed because I'm so deeply in it
you continue like that if I think if you
work three hours a day if you write
three pages if you work nine hours a day
you write not nine pages but 18 pages
one's creativity goes up exponentially
once you devote your life whole life to
it even your sleep to it the way to get
out of our traumas in fact is to invent
a second world fick the world or
artistic world that will avoid the
trauma but perhaps going to a
psychiatrist who understand you may be
something but then maybe you can't write
anymore yes this is the thing that my
friends always tell me or and I see your
trauma time I can give you this pill but
maybe tomorrow your feel happy but you
cannot write again is the central
contradiction in my life perhaps because
i'm happy i cannot write perhaps because
I'm so unhappy i can write these are
reasonable contradictions i think a
right to drive has all of these
variations but in the end
sailing with goodwill and bleeding in
the wind is the essential and you sell
on and on an honor and I'm writing
fiction for the last 40 years after 14
years of sailing I have a sense that
this wind will take me to a nice quite
good beautiful place I trust them in and
sail and say and write and write earlier
this year i sat down with author James
McBride who won the national book award
for the color of water to talk to him
about his memoir biography investigation
into the life of James Brown here he
brings up his recent experiences in what
must have been one of the most
interesting writers rooms ever the
surprise clip is from journalist Charles
Duhigg who wrote the power of habit
talking here about creative teams
about five years ago Google started this
interesting experiment they wanted to
figure out how to build the perfect team
and so what they did is they started
collecting huge amounts of data about
all the teams within Google the teams
that at a glance look most productive
oftentimes aren't but if you can create
this conversational turn-taking equality
of voices if you can convince people to
really listen to each other by being
sensitive to the nonverbal cues or
giving off then you create psychological
safety and psychological safety is the
single greatest determinant in whether a
team comes together or whether it falls
apart one of my favorite examples of
psychological safety and a team really
coming together is the early days of
Saturday alive so when you think about
it Saturday Night Live never should have
worked right you have a bunch of
comedians who are kind of misanthropes
to begin with and yet for some reason
when Lorne Michaels put them in a room
together everyone was willing to kind of
get along they they were willing to put
aside their ego and create this amazing
show together not only an amazing show
but a show that was put together under
these incredible time pressures right
they have a week to put together a live
show and when I talked to the early
writers and performers on Saturday Night
Live and I asked him why that's happened
all of them said the same thing because
of Lorne Michaels so Lorne Michaels has
this very unique way of running meetings
he sits down and the meeting starts and
what he'll do is he'll make everyone go
around the table and say something and
if someone hasn't spoken up a little
while laura michaels will actually stop
the meeting and he'll say Susie I
noticed that you haven't chimed in like
what are you thinking about right now
and it all works out but it's because he
creates an environment that feels safe
where everyone feels like they can speak
up and they feel like everyone else is
genuinely listening to them because
they're sensitive to all the cues that
they're sending
I think that kind of analysis is a dream
killer for me because I think you can
analyze stuff too much you next thing
you know it's like you know analyzing
sex I mean Ashley write a report when
we're done she checklist you know two
fawns 125 at you how was I mean yeah I I
think that kind of thinking is dangerous
for the creative process like if you
come in with that method and no no I
mean whatever mess might have followed
oh yeah I wouldn't find me look I
wouldn't follow what's his name or
Lauren Michael and Michael's I wouldn't
file his method i'd follow my method
everybody has a different solar vaz
different way of singing their song i
think the collaborative process which is
really what the journalist is talking
about is dictated by what you need to
create and who's in the room and so that
process works for that particular group
of people given the time constraints
that exists I don't know that that would
work if you were writing for a six-part
miniseries like i did a i was one of the
writers in a six-part miniseries for
david simon the creative the wire oh
yeah has an aired yet it's called
parting the waters it's about Taylor
branches three book series about the
civil rights movement I'll be watching
myself tiny CC codes Taylor branch David
Simon okay okay now we're going there
what was it like being in a writing room
with David Simon tanahashi and like how
did that go Mahad well it was great I
mean that work it was free I mean David
didn't point that she would say what are
you thinking you know he did it a
different way he said you know we have
to decide which story we're gonna tell
and who's gonna tell it he's like Count
Basie you know I mean he's like Duke
Ellington me like Duke Ellington had a
band of great soloists okay and he'd say
this is the composition now put your
thing to it David is the same way you
know he says this these are the
parameters you all small little kings
and your kingdom let's bring our
kingdoms together and see which one of
us can come up with the best idea where
as the best idea we'll run with that so
you can't bring a lot of ego into a room
like that you have to be you're there to
service the story and a good writer will
service the story a good musician will
service the music as a novelist
how do you work do you plot out
everything before you write or do you
just know i don't i have no standard way
of doing it other than getting up at
four o'clock in the morning and getting
the work you can you can you can write
it four o'clock in the morning okay why
I you know I go to bed at night all
right if I go to bed at eleven I get up
before buck anyway take a nap at 11am
tell you know I mean the discipline of
music taught me how the necessity of
practice but going back to your earlier
statement about this room full of
writers if you are real serious right of
you you are servant to the story you
writing chooses you you don't choose it
so when you're working with other
writers you have to service the idea and
that's really with craft comes in the
trade shows us up because then you have
to be able to throw left handed in bat
right-handed or bat right in and throw a
left-handed I have to be able to you
have to be able to hit a curveball in
the bottom of the seven with two out and
guy on base you just have to be able to
do it because if you don't you bring in
the whole team down so you have to learn
how to play every position you're a
person who's collab you've done music so
you've collaborated with other people
you've done theatre tanahashi has
written a comic book just now you know
so there's a just I think of like some
of these folks you know William Faulkner
you know the folks like sitting alone in
their room for their whole lives would
probably freak out if they suddenly had
to share the table problem oh maybe
maybe I mean but i must say that writing
is a lonely life and so working with
other writers in this particular
situation was just a lot of fun and my
problem is that they're my age you know
I walk into a room and I start talking
to people get intimidated they think
that you know I know what I'm talking
about you know and I reached the point
in my life where I don't really feel
like I'm not I stopped working hard at
trying to make people feel comfortable
if they can't accept me on my own terms
just you know they'll see shortly that
it's cool and if they don't then there's
nothing nothing I right or play or do is
going to make them feel comfortable
anyway so I didn't have that problem
when I was working with David in
arachova myotonic EC and tail
so they would just cool we were all
there for the same purpose and I really
like them all
and I ended an earlier mixtape with a
spontaneous monologue from one of my
favorite writers poet and rapper Kate
Tempest but the whole conversation with
her was incredibly illuminating she had
just finished her first novel the bricks
that built the houses and here she talks
fascinatingly about writers black the
surprise clip is from author augusten
burroughs he's talking about writers
block which he believes is a real thing
and we'll see how kate responds to that
the worst thing to do with writer's
block is kind of like the worst thing to
do with back pain you know if you have
back pain you don't want to stay in bed
for the next five years you know you
need to begin physical therapy you need
to maybe do yoga or pilates you need to
move with writer's block don't stay away
from the writing and think I'll wait
until the solution comes to me because
that's not how it works for a writer the
solution comes to us as we're writing it
comes mid-sentence the solution to
writer's block is to write about the
writer's block why do you have it why
does it suck really why it could be a
case of you knows you're off plot or off
point it could be that there's something
deeper better truer juicier that you
really need to write about that maybe
you're too embarrassed to write
I'm of the opinion that there's no such
thing as right as blood I don't think it
exists I think that there is the fear of
writing badly that's that's what it is
and if you're afraid of right and badly
then you're not going to be writing
because it's a it's a crippling fear
that but you just have to take that fear
away from it and tell yourself if I
write a lot of today it doesn't
matter right right it doesn't matter if
it's not good like who uh-huh because
the the point of it is right anyone can
have an idea anybody but finishing and
ideas so I'm saying that's the agony
that's difficult right it's always
difficult it's hard work and my
apologies for staring no no it's all
good yeah but the point is is that like
you're kind of in competition with
yourself already because you're trying
to improve you're trying to be better
tomorrow than you were yesterday that's
one thing but having an idea beautiful
perfect it's going to be you know it's
going to change the world it's going to
be the best thing you've ever done
though the actual finished thing is
going to be clunky you're gonna be
ashamed of it you're gonna pick it apart
with you can't get to sleep you're gonna
hate yourself for doing it that's the
point yeah that's why you move on and
have another idea you finish things you
finish things they're stepping stones
towards finding a voice it's like on a
writing day if I don't fit if it's not
happening if it's not coming out i don't
i don't force it i take a walk like a
stop like uh huh i'm in a slightly
different situation because i'm usually
i'm usually quite up against it with
deadlines so i wrote the majority of
this the pics that built the house is
kind of what I was on the road torrent
yeah so in a tour bus full of other
people yo boss or in a cafe or in a
service station or like in the three
days I had off between tours in my
bedroom or whatever it was like yeah and
the thing is like you can make all kinds
of excuses that you can say I need some
space and I need time and I need natural
light and I need a room of the view and
I need well you can just you know you
can just finish it yeah it's really hard
but it's what it's what will make you
better say you don't take a walk and say
you sit down and you make yourself right
one day and it comes out and it's
you delete it do you rewrite it it
depends what you're working on so few if
I'm working on a play yeah you can hear
you can feel when it's a bad line
suddenly you're like what nobody would
ever say that but this is how I never
say that all right yeah but the thing is
when when I'm up against a deadline or
usually it's I'm under a lot of pressure
because of my schedule because I I mean
that's the way I work and I'm happy
about it good but sometimes there isn't
time to be having an off day yes and
that's like it's crazy pressure but it
works sometimes it works other times I'm
in a really great situation because
writing can be quite lonely pursuit but
then when you have an editor or in music
I have a great music producer who I work
with or when I'm making theatre I have
you know the director the director and
there are these other people these kind
of midwives that populate a writer's
life that help you to kind of get over
yourself enough to just kind of deliver
it you know right and you know with with
this for example with the bricks the
most exhilarating part of this process
was deleting 30,000 words and feeling
how good that was like right suddenly it
got lighter and it kind of held its
shape a bit more successfully and I
could just feel this thing that I'd only
ever heard writers talk about but I've
never experienced which is like the kind
of joy of just cutting cutting cutting
cutting and just watching it kind of
grow yeah I know it yeah really
interesting one so yeah shut out a lot
of it'll stay there for a bit and
then you lose it it's all right you know
yeah so it sounds like yeah a big part
of your process is kind of the gun to
your head like just saying basically I
got to get this done and putting
yourself in a position where that's the
case yeah and even before when there
wasn't deadlines and I had no publisher
or anything else I was still inflicting
that kind of pressure on myself because
I've always felt that time is kind of
against me I don't know widen if you
feel like that yeah well increasingly
but for me it was interesting because I
I grew up relatively privileged and had
the privilege / curse of being able to
kind of wander around and like it took
me longer to feel the gun of time to my
head right yeah and I mean I don't know
much about your background but I know
from the fact you know that so much of
the press is about your being from south
east London and the neighborhood that
you focus on it stuff I'm guessing you
maybe didn't have people sending you off
to wander around well I didn't get sent
off to wonder
it I grew up you know in a really good
supportive environment but the way that
South London figures him in my work and
in in myself is like it's such a huge
part of me because if you grow up in a
big city especially in a part in a city
that's so South London okay so I suppose
for an American audience to kind of to
say Oh southeast London I probably
doesn't mean anything like you know
unless you've spent some time in London
but the kind of character of it in my
head the way that it is a very creative
place in terms of people were really
making something happen there I felt
it's very mixed place culturally
racially and economically lots of
different people living very close
together there's a certain sensibility
that it gives you if you're from there
which is it's quite a rough area though
it was like the highest the highest
rates of teenage pregnancy and murder
amongst teenagers when I was growing up
in Lewisham which is the bar where I
grew up but at the same time there's a
huge amount of music and huge amount of
amazing vibrant creativity and I found
it to be a really positive place I grew
up in a really good home my dad was a
lawyer my mom is a teacher we just lived
in this area that was like full of full
of life you know it was just full of
life and every time I walked out of the
door and down the street every time I
ever went anywhere I would pass by a
thousands if not tens of
thousands of people because it's London
it's a big city and I just always felt
so close to life you know it was just
everywhere and i have a huge love for
people like a deep love and that's so
obvious to say but i'm really moved by
just like being amongst strangers and
feeling connected to their humanity and
feeling this thing i'm talking about
earlier on about this kind of current of
reality that we are denied access to i
think there is something about a kind of
frequency that a writer exists on
looking for the kind of looking for the
internal experience of strangers you
know I don't really know why but you i
watch somebody walk down the street and
the way that they're carrying their
their car keys something about the way
they just dropped their shopping bag
like I feel so blown away by a tiny
movement so it kind of sends me into
this like deep passion for these people
you know for for somebody and I see
the writer is constantly feeling kind of
outside of life which is what sends us
to the page often you know trying to
write ourselves into this grudge
existence that we were kind of
constantly because we observe so much of
kind of outside of things but the the
observation is one of like pure love
really yeah I got I got lost in South
London it and I found myself there you
know I got into all kinds of trouble and
all kinds of right beautiful beautiful
things happened and and I still lived
there and it's still home you know in
the book there's you talk about
gentrification and there's this sense I
mean it seems like you feel like the
heart of south London is still intact
but that there's this threat somehow of
it being co-opted or change because that
I think it's more helpful because this
conversation about gentrification it
happens all over the world and it's a
tragedy but the minute what I've been
thinking about is it's more useful
actually to pan out of this a little bit
and think about what this means in a
kind of why the framework which is this
kind of symptomatic greed and the
exploitation of land for profit about
people and this you could okay yes it's
a it's a real shame south London's
changing my god it hurts but if we pan
out a little bit and we think about land
land is being exploited for profit the
people that live on that land are being
destroyed their communities their
cultures being destroyed listen just
happening in cities this is happening
all over the world it's happening to the
first Australians it's happening the
rainforest in Peru you know it's like
there is agreed that is running running
the world yeah it's greed oh no there's
no empathy and I think that alienation
happens not only to the communities that
are destroyed but to the Destroyers as
well I mean I just think that the world
that is built up upon the wreckage of
these communities is also a world in
which it's difficult to form community
like new communities yeah I don't know I
mean I don't know I've never lived in a
I don't know i think that like this has
to go both ways so if i say that you
know i love people and that I'm for
people I can't be just for people that I
already agree with
like this has to go both ways you have
to recently I've been thinking okay so
you need to empower even the very
powerful to be more real with themselves
that right actually actually think about
the cost the only thing I can think to
say is just empathy you just need more
empathy it's very easy for artists
anybody to basically cut themselves off
from all the rest of that humanity and
find some way to categorize people and
say like oh that person is too you know
that's a greedy corporate person or
that's of this person or that you know
what I mean like I think it's hard for
anyone to remind themselves mmm and try
to figure out how to like not shut off
it's so difficult because part of me
just recoiled and kind of wishes that
the world was kind of run by these
reptilian monsters the reality is that
they're human beings yeah these are
human beings that are making these
decisions and and so at the beginning of
this conversation we were talking about
you know whether this kind of grappling
between what we're capable of and what
we are what are inherent nature is and
actually why I believe that inherently
we are physiologically empathetic beings
right there was there was a study that
yeah that took place where I learned
about this in the Science Museum in
London so I know it's true right it's
okay though they took two strangers put
them in a room separated by a glass
partition and one of them stood on a
block of ice and the temperature of the
others the temperature of the other
person's feet dropped in response to
watching another human being who they
didn't know stand on a block of ice like
our bodies are tuned into each other's
it's like if I see like if I see your
wound on you I will require it will hurt
me at level right we have to learn
people have to learn not to be able to
do that you know yeah right yeah but so
like it but we kind of fed this thing
about humanity being this like
inherently like aggressive competitive
selfish I don't believe that I think
that that is something that has
encouraged this kind of myth of the
individual which is very helpful for
capitalism but not very helpful for
Humanity you know yeah but what I mean
fear seems to be a pretty strong forest
within humanity as well and it seems to
me that a lot of this stuff arises from
fear right i mean
the primal fear goes all the way back
right i mean we're afraid of death you
know it's probably where it begins I
don't know but fear of scarcity fear of
whatever like fear of somebody taking
what's ours i don't know i think it's
probably pretty old yeah I'm know I'm
with you oh my d and I think I think you
yes of course but like once you are
sounds like kind of far-fetched and also
so easy but this is kind of where I'm at
at the minute is if you're if you're
there if your present with yourself
right suddenly like the the worry of
things the anxiety of things to come
it's not important because you're just
in your just where you are you know yeah
deal with it when it comes but i don't
know i don't know i'm a sudden he was
about to say something extremely kind of
new aeg it's not myself just that's okay
that's not a yes quickly shoot yeah okay
good next subject and that's it for this
think again mixtape which I'm calling
the writers room gathering some of the
most poignant and interesting advice
that I've heard from writers on writing
over the past year if you're listening
and liking the show you're probably sick
of hearing me say it and I wish that I
could personally remove this message
from all the future episodes of everyone
who has gone and done this but at any
rate I can't if you could go and read or
review the show on iTunes stitcher
wherever it is you're listening it
really doesn't take very long and it
makes a major difference in terms of the
show's sustainability we have an amazing
season coming up now there's fall and I
hope to see you next week
you